hey I'm Owen Wilson auditioning for
James Bond how can you believe I'm even
saying that I'm Seth Rogen and I'm
auditioning for bond James Bond hey
what's up girl I'm Justin Bieber yo I'm
cage Nicolas Cage like all the villains
that have dared come up against this
agent there's court is mine all right
Ian McKellen when you're ready just slit
your name I'm James Bond reading for
James Paul no no just say your real name
all right James Bond no double-oh-seven
reporting for duty
okay why why would you cut that was
brilliant
wow what a cool tuxedo it's almost as
cool as that coal or outside
wow what a car I don't think you would
say wow that much Wow you really think
so okay in whenever you're ready magneto
okay not only is that the wrong movie
you just said beg neato I'm Batman no
you're not I'm agent Wow
I like you better without your beretta
oh I feel naked without I'm sorry Ian
could you please oh oh and then I'll be
face to face with my enemy and I'll say
I want to take your face oh I love the
energy but that's a ten and bond is
usually like a fine for me that was the
five well if that's a five we have to
bring it down to a one oh no go any
lower that far